[Musique]
est ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé de
vous sentir complètement submergé par le
flot continu des informations qui vous
arrive tous les jours
ou alors peut-être que ça vous est déjà
arrivé également de lire un super livre
un livre qui vous fait un effet whaou
pour vous rendre compte une semaine ou
deux semaines plus tard qui vous reste
quasiment plus rien de votre lecture
autre exemple est-ce que c'est aussi
arrivé d'avoir une idée lumineuse pour
vous rendre compte que vous avez du mal
à l'expliquer à quelqu'un est ce que des
gens lever la main à ce que des gens se
sentent concernés par une de ces
situations
ce que j'ai exposé en fait ce sont des
problématiques de gestion de
l'information des outils qu'on appelle
des outils de pensée visuel qui vont
faciliter la vie qui vont vous permettre
de mieux gérer cette information alors
sachez que met pas tout seul à avoir
vécu ce genre de situation je me
souviens déjà quand j'étais tout gamin
le fait d'aller à l'école de devoir
apprendre toutes ses leçons ça a été une
vraie souffrance pour moi et ça pendant
toute ma scolarité
je me souviens très bien le dernier jour
de mes études de m'être dit l'école plus
jamais et la vie faisons quelques fois
des tours un peu drôle il s'est trouvé
que quinze ans plus tard je me suis
retrouvé à l'école mais ce coup ci pour
former des profs sur les techniques
d'apprentissage mais ce que voudraient
partager là c'est cette notion de
difficultés j'ai ressenti et quelques
années plus tard lors de la lecture d'un
article par hasard ou presque par hasard
si vous pensez que le hasard existe
j'ai appris qu'il existait des
techniques de lecture rapide et des
techniques de mémorisation et là je me
suis dit c'est pas possible j'ai passé
tant d'années à prendre avec tant de mal
alors qu'il existe des techniques
auraient vraiment pu me me faciliter la
tâche
et pour en avoir le coeur net quand même
j'ai entrepris quelques recherches et
très rapidement je suis tombé sur ce
monsieur ce monsieur c'est tony buzan
c'est l'inventeur du mind mapping et à
ce moment là j'ai acheté un de ses
premiers ouvrages qui s'intitule et une
tête bien faite et dans une tête bien
faite tony buzan explique vraiment les
bases les fondamentaux à la fois de la
lecture rapide des techniques de
mémorisation
mais surtout du mind mapping
le mind mapping c'est une technique de
prise de notes mais une technique de
prise de notes visuel plutôt que de vous
concentrer sur l'exhaustivité et vous
perdant dans l'ensemble des textes vous
allez vraiment cherché à capter les des
clés capter les les mots clés pour les
réorganiser y avoir une vision beaucoup
plus claire de ce sujet deux ans après
cette découverte
j'ai découvert en mettant en pratique
ces outils la puissance qu'ils avaient
pour apprendre c'est à ce moment-là que
j'ai voulu passer un diplôme pour
enseigner les arts martiaux
alors je vous ai pas dit les arts
martiaux c'est vraiment ma première
passion avant le mind mapping et avant
les outils de pensée visuel et quand je
me suis inscrit pour passer cet examen
pour enseigner les arts martiaux
j'ai vraiment reçu une tonne de cours et
une tonne de documents qu'il fallait
apprendre quasiment par coeur
je me souviens il y avait de l'anatomie
la physiologie il y avait de la
réglementation de la pédagogie enfin
plein de domaines qui étaient plus
transverses à après à la pratique des
arts martiaux et qui en tout cas sur le
moment me passionnait pas vraiment et là
vraiment j'ai eu un petit coup de stress
et je me suis dit mais comment je vais
m'en sortir et j'ai repensé à ce livre
que j'avais acheté quelques quelques
années avant qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
tout simplement
j'ai appliqué la méthode j'ai transformé
tous ces textes en my maps on appelle
aussi carte mentale et là vraiment il
s'est passé quelque chose
d'extraordinaire le fait d'adopter un
mode de lecture actifs c'est-à-dire
d'aller chercher vraiment les idées clés
de les transformer sous forme de mots
clés de mettre ses mots clés sur des
branches de façon logique sur la carte
de mathilde touches de couleurs de
transformer quelques informations sous
forme de pictogrammes de dessins simples
le fait de suivre tout ce process ça a
permis à toutes ces informations de
rentrer tout naturellement dans ma tête
sans faire un effort énorme de
concentration et de mémorisation est ce
que j'ai trouvé vraiment le plus beau
c'est que non seulement ça rentrait tout
seul dans ma tête mais en plus j'arrive
et allait réactiver
c'est à dire que j'arrivais à ressortir
ces informations quand j'en avais besoin
au final j'ai obtenu
ce diplôme pour obtenir les armes pour
enseigner les arts martiaux excusez moi
mais le plus beau dans l'expérience
c'est moi qui étais un élève vraiment
plutôt moyen j'ai en plus fini major de
ma promotion lors de cet examen
et ça m'a vraiment scotché et je me suis
dit que je pouvais pas en rester là et
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai eu envie
de partager cette expérience et j'ai
commencé d'abord à travers l'écriture
d'un blog sur internet sur lequel je
m'étais je notais en fait mais compte
rendu de lecture sur les livres sur le
sujet je notais mes expérimentations
mais découverte est vraiment de fil en
aiguille le mind mapping et le monde de
la pensée visuels en général a
complètement transformer complètement
chamboulé ma vie parce qu'aujourd'hui
j'en ai fait mon métier je l'enseigne
jeu l'utilisent au quotidien
à ce stade là peut-être que vous vous
demander mais qu'est ce que c'est
vraiment la pensée visuel j'ai
l'habitude de la définir comme un
ensemble d'outils un ensemble de
techniques qui associe à la fois des
mots et des pictogrammes pour gérer de
l'information alors on va utiliser des
mots sous forme de mots clés et les
pictogrammes ce sont tout simplement des
dessins simples que vous allez pouvoir
dessiner rapidement et avant de
continuer
j'aimerais éclaircir un point pour qu'on
parle le même langage le dessin pour la
pensée visuel c'est à dire ceux cette
notion de pictogrammes
ça n'a absolument rien à voir avec le
dessin artistique c'est beaucoup plus
simple et c'est beaucoup plus accessible
mais je dirais même plus c'est vraiment
à la portée de tout le monde
à ce stade je vois bien vous montrer
quelques exemples d'utilisation de ces
outils pensée visuel par exemple ici
vous avez le mind mapping c'est celui
que je vous ai présenté juste avant
c'est une carte justement c'est un my
maps sur les règles de construction d'un
my maps
c'est typiquement une carte qui va
pouvoir utiliser un étudiant en mind
mapping pour visualiser à la fois ta
sont très globale l'ensemble des règles
de construction et il va pouvoir zoomer
sur un détail sur une branche en
particulier s'il a besoin d'aller
rechercher rapidement une information
est vraiment le mind mapping c'est une
technique très très puissante de prise
de notes
et comme le dirait ma fille une ado tu
or il n'y a pas besoin de faire des
cartes ouf pour que ça marche
voyez ici une carte qu'elle a réalisé
avec sa mère pour préparer un voyage
scolaire
c'est juste simple rapide et efficace
un autre exemple ici vous avez une
planche qui résume un chapitre entier
d'un livre sur le business
pour l'auteur de ce livre j'ai réalisé
une planche comme celle ci pour chaque
chapitre
et ça ça va permettre aux lecteurs de
retrouver très vite à la fois les idées
clés mais aussi la structure de ses
idées au sein du chapitre ça permet une
ré activation immédiate de ce qu'il
vient de lire vous avez ici des
productions de stagiaires au bout de
deux jours de formation
leur objectif c'était de pouvoir
visualiser le processus les processus
les flux d'informations et les flux de
travail au sein de leur service ce qui
était vraiment marquant c'est le niveau
de compréhension des uns et des autres
sur leur métier ils ont compris pourquoi
dans certains services
il y avait certaines certaine latence un
certain délai dans le traitement de
certaines demandent par exemple
et puis ils ont vu pourquoi sur des
processus un peu plus globaux
interservices il y avait des
informations qui circulent qui circule
est moins bien et là vraiment ils ont pu
voir toute la puissance des outils de
pensée visuels pour clarifier
l'information
c'était vraiment une vraie révélation
pour eux vous avez pu voir que
techniquement c'est pas très très
compliqué c'est une écriture lisible des
pictogrammes ça s'apprend et vraiment si
vous vous y mettez si vous voulez
essayer vous allez vous rendre compte
que vous aller très très vite vous
étonner et même peut-être pourquoi pas
devenir champion du monde
et ça c'est une question qu'on pose
souvent mais cyril comment on fait pour
devenir champion du monde mind mapping
à chaque fois qu'on me pose cette
question je suis un peu gêné
je suis un peu gêné parce que je me dis
que c'est pas forcément la meilleure
question à se poser
je sais pas si je dois vraiment vous le
dire mais je vais vous le dire quand
même vous êtes là mais pour remporter à
la fois les championnats de france puis
des championnats du monde de mind
mapping
je me suis très peu entraîné
ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai adapté
mais pratique ce que je pratique au
quotidien
j'ai adapté ces pratiques là pour que
cela corresponde aux grilles
d'évaluation de la compétition et en
analysant un petit peu ce qui s'était
passé pour remporter ces deux
compétitions là j'en suis venu à la
conclusion en fait que je me suis très
peu entraîné parce que c'est ce monde de
la pensée visuel était devenu une
seconde nature pour moi c'est quelque
chose que je fais au quotidien
dès que j'ai une information à traiter
je veux sortir un papier un crayon j'ai
commencé à faire un schéma une carte
mentale ou autre et je pense que là on
tient une question qui est beaucoup
beaucoup plus intéressant une question
qui serait du style mais cyril comment
on fait pour que la pensée visuel ça
devienne une seconde nature
et là j'ai une bonne nouvelle c'est très
simple juste quatre étapes la première
il faut vous initier aux outils faut
vous former sa tombe pas du ciel
et une fois que vous êtes formé il faut
pratiquer deuxième étape la troisième
étape il faut pratiquer et la dernière
étape
vous en doutez peut-être il faut
pratiquer encore il faut persévérer
voyez c'est très simple dans la démarche
mais attention c'est pas parce que c'est
simple que c'est facile
et à force de former des gens je me suis
aperçu que vraiment la difficulté n'est
pas technique écrire de façon vraiment
lisible ça s'apprend c'est même ça
s'apprend même très vite foule dizaine
de minutes et le dessin c'est pareil à
apprendre à dessiner pour apponter
visuel c'est assez rapide
si la difficulté à l'epa technique c'est
parce qu'elle est plutôt psychologique
et là il ya un vrai loup qui se cache
ici parce que pour passer d'une prise de
notes linéaire comme on a tous appris à
faire à l'école à une prise de notes
visuel il faut passer d'un endroit
sécurisé on va juste noté les
informations les unes après les autres
sous la dictée presque de celui qui
parle à une écoute beaucoup plus active
une écoute vous allez analysez vous
allez choisir vraiment les informations
qui vous intéresse et comment les placer
sur votre feuille et pour y arriver il
va vraiment falloir que vous fassiez
face à vous même pour découvrir quels
sont vos points vous aux fausses
croyances et les freins qui limite un
petit peu cette pratique et c'est là où
le voyage dans le monde de la pensée
visuel devient vrai
passionnant et ce soir avec vous je
m'affaire une petite expérience
ceux qui pensent qu'ils ne savent pas
dessiner
est-ce que vous pouvez crier heil très
fort ok il y en a quelques-uns une
deuxième question
ceux qui pensent qu'ils sont
irrécupérables en dessin là je cherche
les causes perdues il y en a
quelques-uns aussi ok ce que je vous
propose ensemble c'est qu'on
déconstruisent cette fausse croyance
apprendre le dessin apprendre le dessin
pour la pensée visuel ça passe juste par
trois étapes la première étape c'est ce
qu'on appelle l'alphabet visuel
si vous êtes capable de dessiner ses
cinq formes de base
vous êtes capable à peu près de tout
dessiner ou plutôt vous êtes capable de
tout représentée grâce au deuxième
principe qui va consister à assembler
ses formes de base pour dessiner votre
produit fini alors bien sûr on va voir
il va falloir parfois les déformer on va
prendre notre carré le lait tiré pour
faire un rectangle mais on va voir
comment on peut faire rentrer ses formes
de base là dans nos lorsqu'on vous
dessinez je vous propose de commencer
par dessiner dessiner une voiture vous
voyez la voiture de profil
ok on va commencer par les roues donc on
va dessiner de cercle ensuite j'ai
dessiné la caisse je vous invite à faire
la même chose en direct je vais dessiner
à la caisse pour sage et prendront carré
justement je vais les tirer et je vais
le coupé au niveau des roues
ensuite valoir que j'essaie de
l'habitacle et pour ça je vais reprendre
mon carré et puis je vais écarter un peu
les côtés pour en faire un trapèze
je vais faire la vitre la portière et
voilà j'ai ma voiture
maintenant je vais avoir besoin de tout
votre honnêteté
est ce que c'est une belle voiture
on est d'accord c'est pas un dessin de
designers on est bien d'accord ok par
contre est-ce que tout le monde voit une
voiture alors si tout le monde voit une
voiture pour moi c'est gagner parce que
mon objectif c'est de transformer l'idée
de voitures en dessin de voiture ces
deux véhicules et de l'information
je vous propose deux autres exemples le
prochain j'aimerais dessiner un crayon
quelque chose pour écrire
qu'est ce que je vais prendre comme
forme dans mes formes de base je vais
prendre mon carré pour dessiner le fus
et en faire un rectangle pour la pointe
je vais tout simplement faire un
triangle
et là j'ai le minimum en termes de
dessin système de représentation pour
quelque chose pour écrire ok pour un
stylo ou un crayon pour avoir un impact
visuel un peu plus important je vais
rajouter juste un clic
ok une mine et puis pourquoi pas épingle
pour l'attacher mais là j'ai un stylo
mais maintenant peut-être que ce n'est
pas l'objet qui m'intéresse mais la
notion d' écrire et comme je vais écrire
sur une feuille
je vais dessiner une feuille
comme j'ai écrit je peux éventuellement
si j'ai le temps de faire quelques
lignes mais peut-être que vous avez à
écrire non pas une feuille ya un roman
avait plein de feuilles à écrire et
regardez il suffit le 4è pour créer
l'effet de tas de papiers le dernier
exemple on me demande souvent est
comment on fait pour dessiner les
personnages c'est compliqué et je vois
souvent ça ça vous parle quand on a
besoin de dessiner un personnage
je vais vous montrer une méthode qui est
vraiment plus facile et qui visuellement
les plus impactants je dessine la tête
san incontournable je vais juste de
faire ça pour le corps voyez la
différence et je peux rendre mon
personnage vivant là je sais comme pour
le stylo tout à l'heure j'ai le minimum
je peux lui faire des yeux par exemple
pour orienter en plus le regard de celui
qui va lire le document est ce
personnage peut-être qu'ils parlent
peut-être que j'ai besoin de noter une
citation importante me suffit juste de
noter la situation ici est de faire
parler mon personnage est peut-être que
c'est tellement important qu'il faut que
mon personnage y montrent que vraiment
l'incitation elle est importante il faut
la lire et je vais juste faire partir
mon bras de l'épaule d'en haut et le
pointer vers la bulle et pour faire le
reste du trajet par un peu plus je fais
une vague deuxième ce que je viens de
vous montrer c'est vraiment le dessin
pour la pensée visuel est la dernière
étape
ça va être comme enjeu peut automatiser
la réalisation de mes pictogrammes point
je fais de la prise de notes visuel et
c'est encore une fois extrêmement simple
je vais me construire une bibliothèque
visuel c'est à dire que je vais prendre
des concepts que j'utilise souvent et je
vais répéter 10-15 font un pictogramme
pour le mémoriser et déjà prendre des
notes
je vais transformer cette idée là en
pictogrammes et ça se fait dans le temps
peut en faire 5 ou 10 par mois
et très rapidement on a une belle
bibliothèque de pictogrammes jouer une
dernière question à vous poser un
vendeur de conclure lever la main ceux
qui se sont un peu réconcilié avec le
dessin qui pensent que c'est au moins
possible moyennant un peu de pratique
ok très bien
en guise de conclusion je vous ai donné
la méthode vous savez comment il faut
faire
vous formez persévérer dans la pratique
jusqu'à maîtriser les outils vous avez
compris que techniquement c'était pas
très compliqué il faut juste passer
quelques freins et j'aurais vraiment
qu'une chose à dire si vous sentez une
sensibilité pour ce que je veux dire
juste à vous de jouer
[Musique]